brian tensions are high here and the
meeting hasn't even started yet you can
see the line behind me is just growing
as we speak many who are having issues
with the mask policy many refusing to
wear masks so this again is a rule to
get into this building the clark county
government center and sit in on the
tonight's ccsd board meeting now another
rule that was put in place that any kind
of rowdy behavior any disorderly
behavior that person will be removed now
you'll remember a couple weeks ago there
were a lot of issues regarding that
people were speaking out against mass in
schools that will no doubt be a topic of
tonight's public comment though there is
no covid related items on tonight's
general agenda now something that is on
the agenda tonight as you mentioned
brian that anti-racism policy trustees
are expected to discuss that this
evening now there was a protest a press
conference held just a little while ago
people were saying that
the board of trustees has not moved fast
enough on the anti-racism policy
claiming that there is still racism in
ccsd schools now we will of course keep
you posted as this continues both of
these issues definitely a hot topic here
creating a lot of turmoil between groups
make sure to stay with eight news now
both on air and online for the latest
and we will of course have the latest at
six and eleven o'clock as well reporting
live tonight sasha loftis 8 news now